dr david agus joins us now david good
morning a lot to talk about here but i
want to start with the
cdc's advisory committee on
immunizations
practices uh which met yesterday
what were the findings what can you tell
us about the findings of that committee
a group of experts got together the
first thing he talked about was
guillain-barre that
that neurologic symptom that was
associated in small number of people
with the j and j
vaccine yeah it was uh slightly more
than you'd see in the general population
but very very rare and they're going to
put a label
on the bottle and just make people aware
of it so if it's caught early can easily
be treated
and then they talked about people they
had a very emotional presentation but a
guy who had a kidney transplant
who said i want that third shot i can
lie and go get it but i want that third
shot
so i can be with my family and it was a
beautiful beautiful speech he gave
in israel they've approved a third shot
for immune suppressed patients we
haven't done so here
and there's a whole cohort of people
that didn't respond to the vaccine
is is um did is there a slightly higher
risk with the johnson johnson vaccine
um with the johnson johnson vaccine
there's a slightly higher risk of
gambere there is a slightly less risk of
the myocarditis or inflammation or the
heart
but they're are really really rare
compared to obviously what the virus can
do
right okay would you still advise people
to get the johnson johnson vaccine what
do you think
yeah i think yeah yes yeah um no
question about it i think there's a
cohort of people in the united states
that they just want one shot we've seen
it some people got the first shot of
pfizer moderna and didn't get the second
and they are not protected against delta
and that group predominantly younger
people
the jng vaccine is perfect for we should
do that
i probably wouldn't give it to someone
who's elderly at the present time
but i would focus on the younger people
a college student who's going to get the
first shot and then move
and probably not show up for the second
one j j is perfect
i still can't stop thinking about these
breakthrough vaccines and the
unvaccinated people that are now
affecting the people right through cases
breakthrough cases that are still
affecting the
vac that are now affecting the
vaccinated people you know
i thought you made such a good point
yesterday where you said everybody has a
right not to take the vaccine
but you don't have the right to affect
others can you compare it to smoking
back in the day
remember when we used to have no smoking
and we used to smoke in restaurants yeah
you know it's interesting what got
america to stop smoking the most with
the second hand smoke argument you have
a right to smoke
in your home right your backyard but
when you go out in public that
secondhand smoke can potentially harm
somebody else
and people understood that and they
responded and that was the biggest
decrease in smoking in the united states
and i think the same is here is that you
have a right not to be vaccinated nobody
will force you
but what we just don't want is that
asymptomatic spread to others
you have to think about your population
your city your family your friends
and your behavior has to be different if
you have not been vaccinated
and now it's affecting the env it's
affecting the vaccinated people
yeah so people are getting sick or
unvaccinated what were you going to say
no i was going to say president biden
wants to see the fda approve
these vaccines by the fall what will
that do
for vaccine hesitancy by the way so do i
it's not just president biden i think
all of us do
yeah what happened is is that many ceos
organizations put a stake in the sand
saying
as soon as there's a full approval i'm
going to require my employees to come to
work to be vaccinated
why is it taking so long to get full
approval that's a great question so it
was submitted may 21st
um you know it's ongoing now the review
my hope and prayers and believe me i am
pushing as much as i can
is that that review will happen as quick
as possible we can get that full review
and we can start to have people stand up
like president macron did in france
and when he stood up and said you want
to go to a bar you need to be vaccinated
millions of people signed up for the
vaccine because they wanted that
privilege yeah and the nfl is taking the
stand too thank you david agus